So, gucken, ob Teams wieder mal ein Mikrofon verstellt hat.
Das macht es ja gerne.
Ja, na klar, was sonst?
Teams, Alter.
Pains Champ.
Massive Pains Champ.
Leute, ich habe euch schon mal auf Twitter gefragt, ne?
Aber meint ihr, externe Experten bzw. und oder Consultants müssen Ahnung haben von dem, was sie machen?
Weil ich habe langsam das Gefühl, dass alle externe Experten, die wir haben, keine Ahnung haben.
Ich frage mich, wie das geht.
Pizze Loser, ihr habt leider auch so einen.
Ja gut, einen.
Einen ist ja...
Ja gut, das stimmt nicht.
Wir haben auch welche, die wissen, was sie machen.
Ja, aber ich sage mal so, 90% haben keine Ahnung.
10% sind ganz okay.
Euler hat mich eine angeschrieben von unseren externen Experten.
Ähm.
Er hat gestern ausgefragt.
Er hat aus Versehen einen Merch-Request aufgemacht.
Und er hat den Merch-Request jetzt quasi selbst abgelehnt, damit der nicht gemercht wird.
Ich habe gesagt, ja okay, solange alles drin ist, was du haben willst, ist gut.
Im Zweifelsfall einfach schließen.
Du kannst ja selbst schließen.
Dann fragt er mich ernsthaft, wie schließe ich denn einen Merch-Request?
Ja gut, hast du doch schon gemacht.
Nein.
Dann hat er gemeint, nein, ich habe abgelehnt und nicht geschlossen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht.
Für so eine Scheiß-Diskussion kriegen die ihr Geld, was jetzt, oder wie?
Ich müsste eigentlich, ich müsste mir den ganzen Scheiß mal aufschreiben.
Meinem Chef schicken, aber gut, was soll der machen, ne?
Der kann sie kicken.
Das war jetzt eigentlich so wild, aber das ist so ein Kandidat, der immer diskutiert.
Immer, wegen jedem Scheiß, ja.
Kennt ihr, kennt ihr so Leute?
Die wirklich von, aus, von bei allem irgendeine Diskussion vom Zaun brechen.
So nach dem Motto.
Ich habe eine Tasse, da ist der Henkel links und ich habe eine Tasse, da ist der Henkel rechts.
Ist der jetzt links oder rechts?
Vielleicht ist er sogar in der Mitte.
Die müssen wegen allem die Diskussion vom Zaun brechen, ne?
Ja, die labern geheuer, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Gut, so, so, so Stonks BWL, so Stonks BWL-Consultant-Typen haben wir auch.
Die kriegen ja ihr Geld wenigstens nur fürs Labern.
Aber wenn du Technik-IT-Experten.
Beziehungsweise Consultant-Leute holst.
Der Name Consultant suggeriert ja irgendwo, den fragt man zu Sachen, wo man selbst keine Ahnung hat.
Aber dass diese Sache nicht der Fall ist, war mir schon eigentlich von Anfang an klar.
Und das beste Beispiel für mich, warum das nicht der Fall ist, ist unser Spezial-Azubi.
Von dem ich euch schon öfters mal was erzählt habe.
Also der, der so gar keinen Plan hatte.
Der, der einen halben Nervenzusammenbruch hatte, wo ich ihn nach Netzwerkgrundlagen gefragt habe.
Haha, genau, der, ähm, der ist ja dann, der ist ja dann weg bei uns nach der Ausbildung, weil ihn keiner haben wollte.
Und was ist er geworden?
Junior-Consultant.
Ich, ich, ich, mir fällt wirklich kein einziges Thema ein, bei was ich den konsultieren würde.
Mir fällt wirklich nix ein, bei was ich den fragen würde.
Das einzige Talent, was der hat, ist, das ist der mit C-Lattenzaun, genau.
Der, der, der statt C-Sharp gesagt hat, das würde C-Lattenzaun heißen.
Haha, genau, der ist das.
C-Lattenzaun, genau, der ist das.
Und, ähm, der schon nicht, nicht geschafft hat, einen Body Mass Index zu programmieren.
Das war eine Übungsaufgabe und das hat man ja dann nicht hingekriegt.
Und irgendwann hat er gesagt, Max, es funktioniert, Max, es funktioniert.
Ähm, und im Endeffekt meinte er halt, es ist kompiliert.
Naja, ähm.
Nix wissen, Kohle schärfeln. Ja, ist echt so.
Max, was hältst du davon, wenn Workstations alle Mitarbeiter durch VMs auf einem Server ersetzt?
Nix.
Der Mitarbeiter hat also nur eine Art KVM-Box auf dem Tisch mit.
Kann das flüssig funktionieren?
Also, theoretisch schon.
Praktisch, nun ja.
Also, ich würde den Unterschied sofort merken.
Irgendwelche Noobs, die halt absolut nix checken, was Input-Lag und Responsiveness angeht, äh, die nicht.
Aber, ja, ne, also, ja, man merkt das auf jeden Fall.
Also, es gibt ja da verschiedene Varianten.
Es gibt einmal diese Citrix-Geschichte mit, äh, die auch Grafikkartenbeschleunigung kann.
Und es gibt diese, ähm, von Microsoft, diese Hyper-V-Geschichte, die auf RDP basiert.
Wo auch Grafikkartenbeschleunigung kann.
Also, das ist quasi ein RDP, der allerdings irgendwie auch für die VMs eine GPU durchreichen kann.
Das geht nur Hyper-V-mäßig.
Und ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt.
Und dann kann man dort auch über RDP 3D-Anwendungen benutzen und sowas.
Also, die Chance, es geht.
Es geht.
Man darf nicht vergessen, im Endeffekt, wenn sowas wie Game-Streaming geht,
dann geht auch sowas.
Ja.
Also, wenn du Game-Streamen kannst, dann geht auch ein lagfreier Desktop.
Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch einfacher.
Allerdings, ähm, ich bezweifle, dass man, dass die das richtig machen und wahrscheinlich eher sparen wollen, dadurch, dass sie die Workstations ersetzen.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es gut funktioniert.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das gut funktioniert.
Also, bei uns, wir haben so eine ganz primitive Geschichte.
Also, quasi eine Windows-VM, wo man per RDP drauf geht.
Und das ist halt laggy as fuck, ne?
Also, der Unterschied zwischen lokal installiertem Windows und einer VM mit RDP ist halt riesig.
Wenn es dieses spezielle GPU-Path-Through-Hyper-V-RDP-Extension-Ding ist, dann ist es okay.
Dann ist es ein bisschen wie Game-Stream, würde ich mal sagen.
Aber Game-Stream funktioniert ja auch nur so flüssig, weil es halt eine GPU durchgereicht hat.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es gut funktioniert.
So, Runde T, ein Schenken.
Exzellent.
Und gerade, wenn man Windows hat, dann machen die doch eh alle möglichen Sachen über Regeln im AD.
Dann kann man doch auch Workstations behalten.
Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es einfacher ist von der Verwaltung.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es auch spart.
Also, zockst du Hyper... Was ist denn Hyper-Stream?
Ach, das ist ja sowieso auf Battle Royale.
Habe ich mir nicht angeguckt.
Ich habe mir nur mal einen Stream heute angeguckt.
Ich finde, das sah auf den ersten Blick gar nicht mal so doof aus.
Aber kann ich noch null zu sagen.
Ähm, ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube, das spart Kosten.
Und es ist einfacher zu verwalten.
Allerdings, die Frage ist, wie weit das wirklich Kosten spart, wenn die Mitarbeiter den ganzen Tag laggen.
Das weiß man nicht.
Oh, habe ich hier noch meinen?
Moment, Moment.
GIF.
Moment, wie ging das mit dem GIF?
Muss man ein GIF starten?
GIF.
Ach ne, das hatten wir auf dem anderen.
Das Allerwichtigste.
Also, ohne GIF im Terminal geht ja nix.
Hast du das mit Ragful mitbekommen?
Ja, hat mich mitgekriegt.
Da gibt es ja eigentlich keinen Weg dran vorbei, das nicht mitzubekommen, wenn man sich da...
...umguckt online.
Ja.
Heute irgendwas geplant?
Ne, ich bin ja auch noch eineinhalb Stunden da.
Ich komm mal on.
Ich komm einfach mal on.
Ah, hier, hier, perfekt.
Wo ist das?
Wo ist das Paper, please?
So, jetzt haben wir das Wichtigste, Leute.
Jetzt haben wir das Wichtigste da.
Jetzt ist das Wichtigste da.
Jetzt ist das Wichtigste da, exzellent.
Wie im Titel steht.
Ja, genau das habe ich vermutet.
Dass es laggy ist.
Wie gesagt.
Die meisten bauen ja dann nicht die ordentliche Geschichte auf.
Also da, wo du halt auch ord...
Wo du GPU hast in der VM.
Wo du RDP Extensions für 3D-Beschleunigung hast.
Oder gar sowas in der Richtung, wie man eben beim Game-Streaming macht.
Sondern die machen halt eine billige Geschichte.
VM und RDP.
Und das ist halt laggy wie Sau.
Da kommst du ja vor wie 1990.
Schlechter.
Ein Raspberry Pi ist heute angekommen.
Was hast du denn vor?
Äh...
Naja, dann loggst du dich halt daheim remote ein.
Und kopierst dir den Code, wenn du willst.
Also wenn einer was klauen will, klaut er auch was.
Man sollte vielleicht eher gucken, dass man Leute hat, die nichts klauen.
Das ist bei uns auch so.
Ähm...
Wir haben...
Überall...
Übertriebene Berechtigung.
Wir verwenden ja auf der Arbeit als Ticketsystem das hier.
Das ist also eines der bekannteren.
Hier, die Dinger da.
Hiera?
Es heißt übrigens wirklich hiera.
Aber die richtig coolen Leute sprechen natürlich Jangira aus.
Was übrigens komplett falsch ist.
Jangira.
Es heißt nicht Jangira.
Es heißt Hira.
Hira?
Nein, es heißt Hira.
Das ist ja japanisch.
Also, zumindest...
Ja, heißt es.
Das sagen die sogar.
Japanische Namen für Godzilla.
Ah.
Ähm, zumindest
bei uns ist es so,
die übertreiben es komplett mit Berechtigung.
Also es geht sogar so weit,
wenn ich ein Ticket hab,
wo ich Bearbeiter bin,
und stell fest, das ist bei mir falsch,
und verschieb das in einen anderen Bereich,
wo es richtig ist,
dann kann ich das Ticket nicht mehr abgeben,
weil ich in dem anderen Bereich
ja keine Berechtigung hab, überhaupt Tickets
zu bekommen. Allerdings hab ich das Ticket
ja noch, weil ich es zuerst in meinem Bereich
hatte und dort das Ticket bekommen habe.
Das ist wirklich Big Brain,
und bei uns sind die Berechtigungen so wir,
ähm, dass
solche Sachen laufend auftreten, ne?
Wenn neue Mit- wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich kennen das ein paar,
wenn neue Mitarbeiter anfangen,
dauert das erstmal drei Wochen, bis sie Zugriff überall
drauf haben. Das ist so lächerlich.
Normalerweise würde ich erwarten, gerade,
wo die sich immer überschlagen, von wegen,
oh, wir haben so geile Prozesse
umgesetzt und sich selbst voll abfeiern,
äh, äh, frage ich mich,
wie es sein kann, warum gibt es dann keinen
Mitarbeiter-Check-In-Prozess, dass es nicht
so drei Wochen dauert?
Das ist nicht sonderlich agil, ja?
So ist man nicht agil.
So, und da bringt,
da bringt Jaira auch nix.
Wie gesagt, das ist Jaira.
Und die haben schon so eine eklige
Seite, wenn ich das sehe.
Also, mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen so,
wenn einer wild will,
dass sein Zeug verschimmelt,
in irgendwelchen Atlassian-Tools ablegen,
dann findet es keiner mehr bei uns.
Das geilste ist,
wir haben Team-Namen, ähm,
also, keine Ahnung,
ich denke mir jetzt mal einen Team-Namen aus, ja?
Sagen wir mal,
wir hätten ein Team Software-Bereitstellung.
Haben wir nicht, ich mach das ja ein bisschen anonym,
aber theoretisch angenommen, wir hätten
ein Team, was sich Software-Bereitstellung nennt,
und man möchte ein Ticket aufmachen,
im Ticketsystem, weil man
auf seinem Windows,
weil man auf seiner Windows 4, ähm,
ähm, Fiverr-Player braucht.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, so.
Da würde man ja von ausgehen,
du gehst, du gehst ins Jaira rein,
und machst ein Ticket auf,
bei einem Bereich, der heißt wie das Team.
Bei uns sind es allerdings Massive
Big Brain, und das
das Jira-Team,
oder Atlassian-Team,
benennt die Gruppen
im Jira anders,
wie die Gruppen wirklich heißen.
Das ist der Wahnsinn. Also dann heißt das Team,
das Team heißt eigentlich Software-Bereitstellung,
auf dem Organigramm
heißt es dann
ITSWDEV
oder so, oder
ITSW, äh,
DEV,
das muss überall anders heißen,
und im Jira heißen sie dann,
ähm, nochmal ganz anders, äh,
da heißen sie dann, ähm,
SW
IT
BLUB, keine Ahnung.
So, und wenn man das, man findet nix,
man findet nix bei uns,
das ist so geil.
Du kannst, du kannst dich auf nix verlassen.
Wenn du den Team-Namen weißt, findest du ihn
nicht im Organigramm und nicht
im, im, im, im Jira, äh,
im Jira. Hast du den Jira-Namen, findest
du ihn nicht im Organigramm und nicht
da, äh, ahhh.
Richtig, richtig gut.
Aber, Leute, meine Frage, wer bei euch
arbeitet bei einem größeren Laden,
das ist fast überall so,
geh ich mal ganz stark davon aus.
Also, bei dem Provider, wo ich
vorher gearbeitet hab, da war's
nicht ganz so wild, das war aber auch nicht
so'n ganz großer Laden, aber es war auch
furchtbar wirr. Kennst du
Redmine? Ja, kenn ich.
Redmine, Alter.
Da, das bin ich,
da sind wir zum Glück, äh,
das haben wir überlebt, Redmine.
Die Musik ist extrem
Pepe Please.
Also, Redmine hab ich, äh, noch nicht
aufgesetzt oder so, aber ich kenn das, ich kenn das.
Äh,
Luku, das,
richtig gemacht ist das nicht schlecht.
Also, ich muss sagen, so von den ganzen
Ticketsystemen, die's gibt,
wo ich schon mal ein bisschen so reingeguckt hab,
find ich Jira eigentlich am besten.
Wenn's ordentlich
gemacht ist. Wie viele
Mitarbeiter hat ein Unternehmen eigentlich?
Äh, Endorphine,
also, ich, äh,
muss dir ehrlich sagen,
das weiß wahrscheinlich keiner so genau.
Weil das
zig, ähm, Tochter
und über und
sonst wie, ach, das, das
weiß keiner. Also, ja,
klar, wahrscheinlich weiß es irgendeiner.
Aber so wirklich wissen
tut das, wenn, wenn du nicht gerade
Buchhaltungsmann bist, wahrscheinlich keiner.
Dann machen sie also komische
Dinger wie, ah, okay, jetzt müssen,
jetzt, jetzt müssen neue Leute bei irgendwie
ner Tochtergesellschaft anfangen, weil man
sonst über ne gewisse Anzahl
käme, wo's dann noch nen neuen
Betriebsratssitz
bräuchte und so Dinger. Das weiß keiner
genau. Das, das, das weiß,
das weiß keiner genau.
Das ist schrecklich mit Ruby und Wraith.
Ach, Ruby und Wraith an sich ist gut, aber Redmine
ist halt eklig. Ja, wie gesagt,
das mit Ragfall hab ich mitgekriegt. Ich kann dazu
gar nicht sagen, ich hab seine Streams nicht geguckt.
Ich weiß nur, ähm, dass er sich
umgebracht hat mit 31.
Und dass er wohl schon längere Zeit ein bisschen
Dachschaden hatte. Aber
genau ist keine Ahnung.
Hat wahrscheinlich schon jeder
auf Twitch ausführlich behandelt. Ich muss
es ja nicht auch noch unbedingt machen.
So, ich mach mal die ganzen Crap, Crap hierzu,
die wir noch von gestern auf hatten.
Das wollt ich grad sagen, das dürft jetzt ja nicht mehr
da sein.
So, wie hieß diese komische Seite nochmal mit diesen,
mit diesen Jobs, die, die ich bemerken wollte?
Jobs for, ey, die, sowas
beknacktes, ey.
Ich wollt mich eben hier ein bisschen kaputtlachen.
Ich hab nix, ich hab nix spezielles
vor, sag ich euch gleich.
Ähm, habt ihr,
haha, habt ihr nix mitgekriegt?
Äh, habt ihr Twitch?
Habt ihr Twitch-Drama mitbekommen?
Ähm,
xQc vs. Ninja
vs. Ninjas Frau
vs. Ninjas Bruder
vs. xQc's Frau
vs. Frag mich nicht alles.
Wie sie sich geflamed haben. Ich hab mich so
kaputtgelacht.
Also wer es nicht mitgekriegt hat,
so die, so die, in drei Sätzen
mal die Erklärung.
Und hat im Stream gesagt, ähm,
die meisten Streamer, die Charity-Events streamen,
bekommen Geld dafür.
Und,
darauf war irgendwie Ninja
angepisst.
Und dann war Ninjas Frau
noch angepisst.
Und er hat xQc ihr geantwortet, so nach dem
Motto, ja, was weiß sie schon mit ihren zwei
Gucci-Handtaschen,
sie hatte da gar keine Ahnung von.
Dann hat Ninjas Bruder drauf
geantwortet und Ninjas Frau.
Dann hat irgendwann noch xQc's Frau
drauf geantwortet und dann haben sich alle geflamed.
Ich hab mich so kaputtgelacht.
Das hat mich so ein bisschen
an YouTube-Drama
2012 erinnert.
Genau, erst Ninjas Frau, dann Ninja.
Ich fand's mega lustig.
Eigentlich total unsinnig, wie sie sich da drüber
gestritten haben.
Kann mir jemand mit dem Raspberry Pi helfen?
Ähm,
Noobs, Noobs.
Noobs ist für'n Arsch.
Nimm ne SD-Karte, mach den Raspbian drauf.
Vergiss Noobs.
Gibt es eigentlich schon was Neues zu Prime?
Also, diesen Streaming-Service,
ich bezweifle auch, dass es den geben wird.
Erstens,
da muss ich jetzt mal was zu sagen.
Erstens, die zuverlässigste Quelle
davon ist 4chan.
Und ich finde, das sagt alles, wenn die
zuverlässigste Quelle 4chan ist.
So.
Und das nächste ist,
Prime, der Name ist
viel zu
ähnlich zu Prime.
Würden die das wirklich rausbringen,
da wäre Amazon sofort am starten, würde die
verklagen, weil Prime und Prime zu ähnlich
ist. Also, wie gesagt, zuverlässigste
Quelle 4chan und
Prime und Prime.
Das wird's im Leben nicht geben.
Was ist deine Theorie zu Dr. Disrespect?
Gut, habe ich ja schon vor ein paar Tagen gesagt, als
ich aktuell war. Meine Theorie ist immer noch
Plattformwechsel. Weil für alles andere
brauchst du zu viele unbekannte
Sachen, da halte ich Plattformwechsel tatsächlich
für am wahrscheinlichsten.
Was es am Ende ist, wir haben alle
keine Ahnung. Welches
Einstiegsgehalt kann man als Informatikstudent
... Moment.
Du bist Informat... Also, du hast
vorher eine Physieausbildung gemacht und bist
jetzt Informatikstudent.
Möchtest du quasi neben dem Studium
noch was verdienen?
Oder bist du fertig mit dem Studium?
Ach, du wirst fertig. Ich habe
ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, aber ich habe gesehen,
dass die bei Heise letztens wieder
ihre Gehalts...
Gehaltsumfrage gemacht haben.
Das ist immer ganz gut,
weil es für Deutschland ist.
Genau.
Ähm...
Was ist mit euch los, Heise? Come on, bruh.
Paywall. Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Ja, aber nee.
Paywall dann halt nicht, ja?
Lul. Also, ich habe
keine Schmerzen damit, dass die Heise Plus haben.
Die müssen ja auch irgendwie Geld verdienen. Aber vielleicht sollte
man nicht auf der normalen Seite
Heise Plus Artikel dann irgendwie
verlinken. Weil ich fühle
mich immer angepisst, wenn ich irgendwo draufgehe
und fang an... Vor allem
bei Heise ist das Nervige, das fängt
hier unten immer erst an, ja? Du scrollst
so drüber und denkst dir, aha, aha, aha, aha,
Paywall. Also irgendwie
zwei Minuten verschenkt für da oben, weil Paywall.
Voll für den Arsch.
Also 40k ist auf jeden Fall
für... Also es kommt
immer ein bisschen aufs
Gebiet an, aber 40k erscheinen
mir auch wenig.
Es kommt natürlich drauf... Also
es kommt extrem auf die
Region an, aber
40k erscheinen
mir, also mal angenommen, wenn es Frankfurt wäre oder so,
auch ziemlich wenig.
Es kommt natürlich nicht nur drauf an,
dass du... Es ist halt auch die Frage Region
und welche Position
das ist. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt
in...
In Support
gehst... Wir haben bei uns im 24
7 Support auch einige
Bachelor-Studenten sitzen,
die Informatik studiert haben.
Ähm...
Dann kriegst du auch nicht viel, weil
Support wird dann nicht bezahlt.
Also, na? Es kommt
drauf an, welche Stelle und es kommt
drauf an, welche Region. Dann kann man was sagen.
Ähm...
Immer Brutto.
Also
von Netto-Jahresgeld, dann redet kaum
einer. Auch die
ähm...
Auch wenn die den Tarifvertrag oder so haben,
sind alles Brutto-Jahresgelder.
Beziehungsweise Monatsgelder im Tarifvertrag, warum auch immer.
Was für uns gut ist, weil bei uns gibt's
14 Monatsgelder.
Stepstone Gehaltsbericht. Genau, da
kannst du tatsächlich gucken.
Da kannst du sogar... Die haben sogar so einen Test,
den du machen kannst.
Die haben sogar so einen Test,
den man machen kann, äh, wo du Fragen
beantworten musst, also zu
deiner Person und dann sagen die, was es im Durchschnitt
so gibt. Das ist aber natürlich drauf
angelegt. Du sollst dich da registrieren und
bla und sonst was.
Oh, Consulting. Muss das jetzt
sein? Wirklich?
Consulting.
Was? Überblick.
Brutto-Durchschnittsgehalt.
Personalverantwortung. Ja? Nein.
Anzahl Mitarbeiter unterstellt.
Aha.
Okay, nee, wir wollen...
In welchem Bereich? Gucken wir mal. Zeig mal her.
Äh, Gelder von Fach-
und Führungskräften. Ein Überblick.
Ah, was? Guck mal.
Was macht man da jetzt am besten?
Ah, Branchen. Gehälter nach Branchen.
Banken.
Also, ich habe mir das ja alles
nicht ausgesucht, ja? Aber ich stelle
immer wieder fest, dass ich echt in einer guten Ecke
gelandet bin. Also sowohl Frankfurt,
sowohl Bank,
als auch sowohl, was
der Tarifvertrag hergibt, als
auch, was am Ende noch rauskommt, obwohl ich nur
Teilzeit arbeite. Ich hab...
Es war nie... Ich hab's
nie drauf angelegt, aber ich hab irgendwie echt Glück gehabt
in der Richtung. GG, ja?
Also, so viel haben wir nicht.
Wobei ich mir ehrlich...
Nein, ich weiß es nicht. Das kann durchaus
sein, dass wir über tausend haben, wenn die ganzen
Tochtergesellschaften und Gedöns mit dabei
ist. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keinen blassen Schimmer.
Also,
Gehälter nach Bildungs...
Abschluss.
Ojo, da hast du schon...
Da hast du schon einen
verkehrt, ne?
Gut, inwieweit das jetzt so ein Bachelor
da was bringt,
stimmt halt null. Naja, auf jeden
Fall, in der Grundlage wird das schon sein.
Dass es jetzt nicht
auf den Einzelnen zutrifft, ist ja auch klar.
Sowas ist ja immer
über alle Sachen durch...
Ab 25 Jahren,
okay. Berufserfahrung 25
Jahre, da brauch ich noch ein bissl für.
Wer zählt als Akademiker? Kein
Schimmer. Das ist ja grad die Frage hier. Man
erkennt's nicht wirklich. Top 5
Studienfächer, Medizin und... Moment, was?
Moment.
Ich dachte, es wär IT.
Ach, Moment.
Das ist nicht nur IT,
das ist alles.
Für Führungs... Ach, Moment.
Wir haben voll den falschen Report, Alter.
Zahntechnik.
Was ab Seite 16?
Wo sieht man die Seitennummer?
Ah, da unten. Seitennummern sind out, ne?
IT
hier, GRIP.
Na gut, guck mal, was hast du hier?
Du hast Ärzte, du hast Finanzstorchs
Menschen, irgendwelche Anwälte,
Banking, Ingenieure,
Unternehmensberater, Vertrieb, IT, Marketing.
Ah, ich bin ja immer froh, dass Marketing
bei sowas relativ weit unten ist.
Personal, oh ja, oh!
Jawoll! Marketing,
Personal, PR. Der ganze Crap, der kann
noch viel weiter runter.
Naturwissenschaftliche Forschung und Labor.
Okay, das dürfte ruhig weiter oben sein.
Äh, ja,
Einkauf, Logistik. Na gut, das ist
im Lager hin und her fahren. Bildung.
Ja, dass das so schlecht bezahlt wird, gerade
Bildung sollte eigentlich besser bezahlt werden.
Gesundheit und soziale Dienste. Das, was alle
brauchen, wird am schlechtesten bezahlt.
Design und Gestaltung, technische Berufe.
Also mit technischen Berufen meinen sie jetzt in dem Fall
nicht IT, sondern
äh, was mit Holz, zum Beispiel.
So.
Die Gehälter für IT-Berufe
im Überblick. Ah ja.
Brutto
Durchschnittsgehalt. Okay,
das ist...
Ja gut, das sagt jetzt für den Einzelnen
nicht wirklich was aus.
Das Durchschnittsgehalt ist
unheimlich viel höher
als das, was die meisten Leute
kriegen, weil es halt wieder ein paar gibt, die
extrem viel bekommen.
Deswegen ist ja auch das Durchschnitts...
ähm, das
durchschnittliche...
Wie nennt man das?
Einkommen und sowas, was die Leute in Deutschland
haben, insgesamt
ganz okay. Wenn du aber mal
guckst, wenn du mal so die
allerreichsten weglässt und die allerärmsten weglässt, dann
ist es halt doch nicht so viel.
Und noch schlimmer ist, wenn du die guckst,
die Grenze
zwischen Arm und Reich, wo die liegt.
Das ist viel niedriger,
als man denkt.
Hessen. Guck mal, ich hab echt Glück gehabt,
muss ich sagen.
Also, ich mein,
was hatte ich eben gesagt?
Bank?
Ja.
Bank? Hessen?
Ulm!
Guck mal, Elotrix verdient
65.000.
Ähm...
Ich hasse Ulm.
Ulm sackt so hart.
Ich musste da jahrelang hinfahren.
Ich mag Ulm überhaupt nicht.
Moment.
Jetzt hab ich drüber
gescrollt gerade.
Wo war IT?
Ja, also.
65k
53k
Geschlecht
männlich, weiblich
Anteil variables
Gehalt 8%
mit Personalverantwortung 24
Okay.
Und Hessen. Tja.
Hast du Elotrix mal besucht?
Nein. Warum sollte ich?
Wie
viel meinst du kriegt
ein fachinformatischer Anwendungsentwickler
nach der Ausbildung in Frankfurt?
40k. Ja.
Ja.
Das geht schon.
Je nachdem, wo du hinkommst. Vielleicht sogar mehr.
Aber 40k in Frankfurt
als Einstiegsgehalt, als Anwendungsentwickler,
wenn es jetzt nicht total die Klitsche ist.
Ja.
So, also. Moment.
Ich wollte doch jetzt mal gucken. Gibt's da jetzt irgendwie noch nach
irgendwie Ausbildung
was man gelernt hat oder sonst was? Ne.
Na gut.
Der Gehaltsbericht.
Okay. Ach, hier kommt. Gehaltsunterschied nach
Aufgaben, Fälle und Berufserfahrung.
IT-Architektur.
SAP. Überall
diese SAP-Crap. Aber
der verkauft sich gut. Beziehungsweise
bringt gut Kohle.
Projektmanagement, IT-Beratung.
Ja, von denen hatten wir es ja gerade am Anfang.
Leute, die den ganzen Tag
heiße Luft fabrizieren. Zum größten Teil.
Nicht alle, aber zum größten Teil
sind die
sehr gut im heiße Luft fabrizieren. Aber wirklich
Ahnung haben sie nicht. Softwareentwicklung,
IT-Infrastruktur, Support.
Tja, da sieht man es mal.
Support wird meistens recht schlecht bezahlt.
Top-Berufstitel.
IT-Manager, IT-Architekt,
Software-Architekt,
SAP-Inhouse-Consultant.
Ähm.
Ist das dann
ein...
Ist das einfach jemand...
Was ist ein Inhouse-Consultant?
Ist das einfach jemand, der sich damit gut auskennt
und dort angestellt ist?
Also quasi ein SAP-Experte,
der dort direkt angestellt ist?
Ich meine, den könnte man
auch anders nennen. Den muss man nicht SAP-Inhouse-
Consultant nennen.
Ja, das war es. Okay, das war jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig aufschlussreich.
Senior Software-Ingenieur
in... Moment.
SAP-Inhouse-
Consultantin.
So geht es ja nicht.
So geht es ja nicht hier.
Hehe.
So.
Habe ich eigentlich meinen Chat-Log
angeschmissen hier? Wo ist mein Chat-Log?
Ja, das haben wir uns noch nicht gerade
angeguckt gehabt.
Ach so, ja.
Den Gehaltsplan haben wir schon mal gemacht.
Und die haben uns extrem krass gebetet.
Erstens habe ich weniger
gekriegt, laut Gehaltsplaner, als ich jetzt kriege.
Und...
ähm...
Ich sollte mich danach registrieren, dass er
richtig funktioniert.
Was ist denn eine CAM-Programmiererin?
Das hat wahrscheinlich nichts mit
Webcam zu tun, oder?
Neradon
Stufe 1, 12 Monate.
Excellent Subscription.
Dankeschön.
Board-Netzwerk-Entwickler.
Datenschutz-Koordinator.
CAD-CAM-Programmierer.
Networker.
Integrations-Nachrichtentechniker.
Der Name klingt so richtig oldschool.
Aber richtig deutsch klingt der
Nachrichtentechniker.
Prüf-Technik-Test-Koordinator.
Jobs für IT.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
60329.
Was haben die denn Schönes?
Wir haben schon eine Weile nicht mehr geguckt.
Da ist bestimmt wieder der
irgendwas drin, wo wir ein bisschen flamen können.
Ah, Praktikant.
MV Diverse im Bereich Shopper.
Shopper-Marketing.
Sind das Motorradfahrer?
Nestle. Okay, okay.
Was wollen die denn von so einem Praktikant?
Ach, guck mal, Bewertung.
Was ist mit der Mario-Kart-Musik los?
Warum wird die auf einmal so laut?
OKS.
Moment, das ist die
Lobby von
Mario. Ah, exzellent.
Ja, nein, nein, nein.
Das machen wir nicht nochmal.
Nestle für einen Praktikant.
Okay, bla bla bla.
Können wir alles einmal überspringen.
Welche Rolle nehmen sie ein?
Im Shopper-Marketing.
Ah, das sind die, die einkaufen gehen.
Das sind die Shopper.
Sie arbeiten als kategorieübergreifende
Schnittstellen strategisch mit Marketing.
Als Praktikant?
Im Rahmen der digitalen Shopper-Ansprache.
Was ist denn das für ein bescheuerter Satz?
Der ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Sie unterstützen
im Rahmen der
digitalen Shopper-Ansprache
und entwickeln... Was ist das für ein Satz?
Der ergibt keinen Sinn.
Ich kann den Satz nicht mal richtig aussprechen,
weil ich immer denke, da fehlen Wörter.
Sie unterstützen im Rahmen der
digitalen Shopper-Ansprache
und entwickeln
digitale Kampagnen in Zusammenarbeit mit
Startups.
Das ist massive
Stonksprache. Und mal ganz davon
abgesehen, als Praktikant?
Was soll ich für einen Link öffnen?
Was soll ich
für einen Link?
Von Heise.
Okay, warte mal.
Was ist denn das eigentlich für eine...
Was ist das für eine Uhr?
Na gut, war es auch immer.
Marktübliche IT-Gehälter. Helpdesk und Support.
Gut, das ist immer ganz unten
sowas, ja. Leider.
Datenbankadministration.
Netzwerk, Telekom, Softwareentwicklung.
Beratung, IT-Sicherheit.
Management.
Okay.
Prozentil.
Wo bin ich?
Also früher hätte ich mich dazu gezählt,
aber ich mache keine Administration mehr.
Schon seit Jahren nicht mehr.
Da bin ich am ehesten...
Bin ich auch nicht.
Mich gibt es nicht.
Was sind denn Prozente?
Also die unteren 25%,
dann irgendwie...
Oder was wollen sie hier?
Und dann die oberen 5%.
Irgendwie das sind die oberen 5%.
Und das sind die
unteren 25%.
Das ist so der Durchschnitt.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, das ist nicht so richtig.
Das hier finde ich...
Ich will noch ein bisschen ablästern über Nestle.
Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich.
Mal ganz im Ernst.
Die wollen doch nicht,
dass das wirklich jemand umsonst macht, oder?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Die wollen, dass das hier jemand umsonst macht?
Die müssen da doch schon was für kriegen.
Ansonsten wäre das doch komplett affig.
Ja, da muss es Geld für geben.
Aber da steht halt nichts zu.
Da steht nichts von Gehalt.
Aber wenn das wirklich kostenlos ist,
dann wäre das echt...
Ich meine, das ist ja geschenkt.
Naja. Na gut.
Aber was hat Nestle so
für Bewertungen?
Leider bestenfalls
Durchschnitt.
Relativ viel Pause.
Im Normalfall kann man eher mal nach Hause gehen.
Einen anderen Schicksal...
Also sie finden,
dass Nestle suckt zum größten Teil.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Stärken. Pünktliche Gehaltsebene.
Gehaltszahlung.
Okay, wenn das schon die Stärken sind.
Ich meine, herzhaft, pünktliche Gehaltszahlung
ist keine Stärke.
Pünktliche Gehaltszahlung ist die Basis,
auf der man
länger als einen Monat dahin zur Arbeit geht.
Also, ohne pünktliche Gehaltszahlung
gibt es auch keine Arbeit.
Viele Zulagen.
Sommergeld, Weihnachtsgeld, Urlaubsgeld, okay.
Spontan, freien Urlaub, meistens ohne Probleme möglich.
Also mit Schichtsystem
scheint er zu sacken.
Zehn Monate.
Dankeschön.
Subscription.
Was? Wo steht das? Human?
Hier steht nix mit humaner Arbeit.
Kann man hier sortieren,
nach was ist das Unternehmen
mit der schlechtesten Bewertung?
Okay, die Mario Kart Musik,
die geht mir auf den Keks,
weil die ist unterschiedlich laut.
Wobei, jetzt geht's eigentlich.
Hat sich eingekriegt.
Ich muss was anderes machen.
Was ist letztens?
Ah, yes, excellent.
Das ist schön entspannt.
Was neben der Suchleiste
erweitert?
Bewertung.
Ne, kann man nicht.
Man kann nicht nach Bewertung suchen.
Das wäre auch zu geil.
Ich wollte mal nach dem
schlecht bewertesten Unternehmen
suchen, aber das geht anscheinend nicht.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Was haben die sonst noch Schönes zu bieten gerade?
Oh, Nestle Praktika.
Ne, das muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Technischer Projektmanager für den Bereich
Spritzguss.
Das war's für den Chat.
Kannst du bei Kuhn...
Was? Kuhn...
Okay, ich will das
schlecht bewertetste IT-Unternehmen
in Deutschland haben.
Kann man da nach Branche suchen?
IT.
Hier, alle Branchen.
Äh...
IT.
So, und jetzt Bewertung.
Bewertung absteigend.
Äh, Bewertung aufsteigend.
Kann man mindestens
Bewertung?
Weil die kennt ja keiner hier.
Die sind ja
komplett unbekannt alle.
Die haben doch nicht mal Bilder.
Oh ja, die sucken alle heftig.
Die sucken
hardcore.
Bewertung absteigend.
Die haben auch alle kein Bild.
Warum haben die alle kein Bild?
Okay, die Suche ist doof.
Okay, dann suchen wir nach
wer hat die meisten Bewertungen.
Anzahl Bewertungen.
Ah, gibt's nicht.
Ah, das ist ja doof.
So, schauen wir mal, was haben die denn hier schönes.
SAP, ja, überall.
Überall ist es.
Was, Bewertung ab?
Ja, nee, ab
Sterne, aber ich will ja sagen ab, äh,
viel abgegebener Bewertung.
So, was haben die hier schönes noch für
für uns hier?
Ah, wir gucken, nee, nee, nee, Leute, wir gucken mal wieder.
Wir gucken mal, was unser
Lieblingsunternehmen in Frankfurt so
treibt. Wir müssen uns mal wieder
Telekom-Stellangebote angucken.
Die sind immer am lustigsten, was die da teilweise für
Buzzwords um sich, um sich hauen.
Moment, das ist aber
nicht das, was ich, was ich meinte hier. Jobs.
Wir müssen uns mal wieder die Telekom angucken.
Ja, genau, da sind wir.
Deutschland. Ja.
Frankfurt.
Allein schon, wie bescheuert man hier
reinscrollen muss.
Ja, das ist das Interessante in Frankfurt.
Da, da, in der Ecke.
Niederrad, nee.
Nee, nee, doch nicht. Da.
Excellent.
Was, was, was will der Bachelor?
Äh,
Fachinformatiker, das sind Ausbildungsstellen,
sowas in der Richtung, oder?
Weil niemand sucht ein Fachinformatiker Systemintegration,
das ist Ausbildungsstellen.
Werkstudenten, Ausbildungsstellen,
oder irgendwie sowas.
Die Seite ruckelt übrigens.
Head of Competence Center IT Industry
Lie... What?
Hunter.
Einen Hunter suchen die.
Von KS.
Ja. Okay, Telekom sucht
gerade nix.
Ah, die Telekom sucht Azubis.
Äh, wie weiß man,
wie man sich eigentlich nennen kann?
Kommt drauf an, auf was du dich bewirbst.
Wenn du Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration gelernt hast,
danach sucht keiner.
Du musst halt irgendwas suchen,
dann was zu deinem Kenntnisstand entspricht.
Von Softwareentwicklung
bis Administration,
bis Automatisierungsgeschichten,
bis Cloud, bis sonstwas.
Was halt passt zu dem, was du kannst.
Was ist das denn?
Taze, was ist das denn?
Oh, excellent.
Das sieht...
Das ist bei der Polizei Hessen.
Also diese Seite sieht aus
wie von 1992.
Wer das auch immer erstellt hat.
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Aber einen Vorteil hat's,
man kann's relativ gut lesen.
E13. Moment, E13,
gab doch kaum Geld, oder?
Das hab ich doch schon mal geguckt.
E13, ähm...
E13 gibt's doch kein Geld für.
E13...
Was ist das? Stufe 1? Stufe 4?
Keine Ahnung. Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ach, Moment, netto bleiben.
Netto bleiben. Okay.
Okay, Moment, ich hab nix gesagt.
Das sind ja die einzigen,
die das netto machen.
Naja.
Naja, so schlecht ist das doch gar nicht.
Was ist denn Klasse 1?
Sind das Berufsjahre oder sowas?
Morgen KFs?
Ist doch ordentlich.
Ich hab leider keine Ahnung,
was diese Stufen hier unten sind.
Stufe 1?
Stufe 2?
Also das heißt, Stufe 6 wirst du irgendwie nach 20 Jahren oder so.
Okay, dann gehen wir mal was von
halbwegs realistisch machen. Achso, wie ist
das eigentlich? Wird das einem angerechnet?
Also mal angenommen, theoretisch,
jemand hat jetzt wie ich
seit 2007
schon
quasi Berufserfahrung,
das heißt 13 Jahre,
wird das dann
angerechnet?
Weil, wenn das nicht angerechnet wird, was ist der Blödsinn?
Schau dir mal die Schweiz an.
Es gibt nichts zu vergleichen.
Das geht doch halbwegs.
Also, ich meine, das ist jetzt
nichts, wo ich sagen würde,
ich muss sofort hier dahin,
aber das sieht doch schon mal ganz okay aus.
Okay, was schreiben sie?
Was suchen sie überhaupt? Eine Informatikerin,
eine Informatikers
im Bereich,
warum suchen die keinen Informatikor?
Im Bereich Kriminaltechnik.
Oh, richtige Hackermans suchen die, ha?
In Vollzeit.
Eine Gruppierung erfolgt,
Moment, da gibt es auch noch so
andere Abstufungen.
Moment, das ist das, was wir gerade schon hatten, ne?
Das ist das, was wir gerade schon hatten, also passt, passt.
Das
bla bla bla bla.
Die Aufgabengebiet
umfasst die Gewährleistungsbetrieb der
KTI,
okay, Entwicklung von
speziellen IT-Lösungen
und Erstellung von
für das, was ist denn das?
Kriminaltechnische
Institut, okay, Abkürzung,
Abkürzung, immer gut.
Bla bla bla.
Okay,
da muss man aber schon
von dem Thema Ahnung haben.
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht,
was die genau wollen
mit
mobiler IT-Verfahren zur Analyse
und Rekonstruktion von Tatordnungen.
Sollst du
Festplatten entschlüsseln oder wie?
Was ist aus dem Projekt mit Traffic geworden? Hat alles funktioniert?
Ja. Leitung von
Projekten zur Einführung von IT-Anwendungen,
Datenbankings, okay.
Das könnte man vielleicht auch in den Titel
schreiben, weil
Projektleiter ist ja nun mal ein bisschen was anderes
als einfach
Hackerman.
Planung, Beschaffung, Inbetriebnahme von
Moment, die wollen einen Projektleiter
und gleichzeitig einen, der einen Computer anschließt?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen.
Technische Analyse
und gegebenenfalls Beseitigung von
IT-Anwendungen, okay.
Gewährleistung der Umsetzung der für
die Landesverwaltung geltenden IT-Sicherheit,
blablabla, okay.
Mitarbeiter in Gremien, beziehungsweise
ja, okay, also ich könnte jetzt mit den meisten
Sachen gar nicht so wirklich was anfangen.
Oder vergleichbar gute Kenntnisse
in der Entwicklung und Pflege von rationalen
Datenbanken, Microsoft SQL Server.
Weiche,
der Teufel.
Postgres beste.
Kenntnisse und Erfahrungen im
Projektmanagement.
Also ich finde das, also das liest sich alles ganz
okay, aber das meiste liest
sich halt wie so ein ganz klassischer
Turnschuh-Admin.
Der halt unterwegs ist und guckt, dass alles
funktioniert und es liest sich nicht nach
einem Projektmanager.
Ausgeprägt, ja, blablabla.
Herr Doktor Aalhorn.
Hoffentlich
lässt er nicht den Aal raus.
Ah, das war schlecht. Ich geb's zu.
Äh, Aalhorn.
Ah, alles klar.
Ja gut, ähm, ich muss euch
es liest sich gar nicht so schlecht,
aber ich kann mir wenig darunter
vorstellen, muss ich auch gestehen.
Ein Follower ist raus.
Ähm. So, also genau,
die Telekom sucht Azubis.
Und die suchen die, suchen die überhaupt eine Ausbil...
Suchen die überhaupt... Ja, Ausbildung.
Boah, was man als Azubi mittlerweile
kriegt, ist ja heftig. Na gut,
bei mir ist das ja auch schon ewig her.
Selbst wenn du
einfach jedes Jahr ein bisschen was drauf haust,
bist du dabei jetzt schon... Ja.
Naja, bei mir ist das irgendwie
15 Jahre her ungefähr.
Und wenn du dann irgendwie pro Jahr nur
nur 2-3% drauf haust, bist du ja
schon bei dem Gehalt. Im Prinzip, ne?
Ist da da eigentlich gar nichts gegen zu sagen.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, es ist Frankfurt.
Frankfurt ist immer teuer.
Stories.
Nachdem Khaled Deutsch gelernt hat,
lernt er jetzt seinen Traumberuf.
Hä?
Was hat das mit der Stellenanzeige
zu tun? Khaled kommt aus Syrien
und muss erst Deutsch lernen, bevor er seine Ausbildung hat.
Zum Fachinformatiksystem, wenn er gerade so
beginnen konnte. Er liebt es jeden Tag
etwas neu... Okay, die Telekom möchte
sich als besonders inclusive
darstellen. Verstehe, das ist ja gerade aktuell
im Trend.
Er ist begeistert von Sachen, die er sagt.
Sowohl in der Schule als auch im Ausbildungsbetrieb
sind wir ein gutes Team.
Ah ja.
Wo ist Khaled?
Ah, ich dachte, da gibt es wenigstens
ein Bildchen zu, wie er einen Server einbaut oder sowas.
Excellent.
Agile Coach. Das ist was für mich.
Der Agile Coach.
Jawoll. Ich wollte schon immer agil
bei der Telekom sein. Was geht hier ab?
Agile Coach.
So, so, also, okay.
Sie kreieren in der Orga...
Oh, das ist
so ein richtiger Stonks-Job, Alter.
Sie kreieren in der Organisation
den nötigen Rückenwind
auf unserem Weg in die Zukunft.
Als Agile Coach
mit in der Praxis
gefestigten Methodenkompetenz.
Was zum Geier soll das
überhaupt bedeuten?
Mit Herzblut...
Okay, das ist ja auch nichts für mich,
aber was heißt das überhaupt?
Mit Herzblut
arbeiten sie an folgenden Themen.
Sie ergänzen da schon bestehende
Agile-Chapter-Team,
das sich mit der Vereinfachung von Prozessen
beschäftigt, so wo das Thema
Time-to-Market als Fokus hat.
Also sprich, wie schnell kommt was raus?
Sie gestalten aktiv den Weg der Weiterbildung
durch das Agile-Chapter.
Das liest sich heftig bei Instagram, Alter.
Ähm...
Sie fördern
die Entwicklung eines agilen...
Ah, Moment, jetzt ist es agil.
Eines agilen Mindsets vermitteln
agile Werte
und Praktiken und treiben
die kontinuierliche agile
Kompetenzentwicklung voran.
Okay.
Und jetzt nochmal auf Deutsch.
Was macht man da genau?
Durch die Unterstützung und Schule
vieler Methodenkompetenz
befähigen sie die Teams dazu, diese Methoden
dauerhaft und nachhaltig anzuwenden.
Ihre Stakeholder
sind Tribe-Leader.
Okay.
Ja, ich hab die Begriffe alle schon mal irgendwie
gehört, aber ich hab noch nie
so viel, so viel in kurze...
also so viel zusammen
komprimiert gelesen auf einen...
auf einem Flag.
Also ihre Stakeholder
sind Tribe-Leader.
Tribe-Leader, also bei
Scrum ist es so, dass
unterschiedliche Gruppen, die
unterschiedliche Themen bearbeiten,
sind Tribes. Warum man es nicht Gruppen nennt,
weiß ich nicht.
Weil es cooler klingt.
Ne, also wenn du die erste Gruppe hast,
die sich mit Thema A beschäftigt
und die zweite Gruppe, die sich mit Thema B beschäftigt,
dann könnte man das Gruppen nennen
in Scrum sind es aber nicht, sondern es sind Tribes.
Weil
Stonks Menschen das geiler finden,
wenn das so heißt, dass man das nicht versteht.
Es sind, es sind eigentlich Gruppen.
Ja, Gruppenleiter sind das. Gruppenleiter.
Im Endeffekt.
Und die hier halten, halten
was machen, wenn die
wenn die Veganer sind.
Painschamp.
Management- und Führungskräfte sowie Mitarbeiter
sammeln Hierarchie-Ebenen.
Stakeholder sind im Prinzip, die es zu verantworten haben.
Oder die da irgendwie mit drinnen hängen.
Wie kann man das am besten beschreiben?
Was?
Wie kann man am besten Stakeholder beschreiben?
Stonks Chat. Ihr kennt euch mit sowas aus.
Mit so BWL-Kram. Ich nicht.
Was genau ist die Definition
von einem Stakeholder?
Person, für die es aufgrund ihrer
Interessensanlage von Belang ist,
wie ein bestimmtes Unternehmen sich verhält.
Teilhaber. Ah.
Okay.
Investoren. Aber in dem Fall sind es ja gar keine
Investoren.
Ich hätte auch gesagt, das sind die, die es verantworten müssen.
In dem Fall.
Und deswegen halt auch Interesse daran haben.
Gut, was auch immer.
Sie sind Vorreiter.
Die Yoshi-Musik passt da ganz gut zu.
Sonst wirst du hier komplett verrückt.
Okay.
Also sie sind Vorreiter und Botschafter
in der Agilisierung.
Was ein Wort!
Agilisierung.
Agilization.
Und eine Persönlichkeit,
deren Fokus auf
People-Business liegt.
Aktuell ist People-Business aber schlecht.
Und die Begeisterung und Freude
an der Organisation im Winkel besitzen.
Ihre Basis für ihren Erfolg bilden folgende
Erfahrungen und Kompetenzen.
Mehrjährige praktische Erfahrungen
als Agile Coach mit Zertifizierung.
Okay.
Was für eine Zertifizierung brauche ich da?
Zertifizierung Agile Coach.
Weiterbildung
zum zertifizierenden Agile Coach.
So eine Scheiße gibt es echt?
Mein Gott, das ist...
Dieser ganze
Bullshit
ist einfach nur dazu da,
um so einen Geldkreislauf
zu generieren.
Genauso wie dieses ganze
ISO
DIN ISO 9001
ITIL sonstigen Geschiss
Zertifizierungsgedöns.
Das ist einfach nur da, um so einen
Geldfluss zu generieren, das sich selbst
mit Geld versorgt.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es bei den einzelnen Modellen
nicht sinnvolle Sachen gibt.
Klar, hier steht in ITIL auch
sinnvolle Sachen drin.
Aber dieses ganze Geschäft, was da drum herum
gemacht wird,
ist einfach,
dass sich das ganze System da selbst
mit Geld versorgt.
Scrum an sich ist super, die meisten machen es nicht richtig.
Genau.
Die meisten stellen sich mit 15 Leuten hin,
labern 45 Minuten jeden Tag,
setzen sich nicht dabei hin und sagen, wir machen Scrum.
Und wenn du sie fragst,
okay, was war jetzt hier dran Scrum?
Ja, weil wir uns nicht hingesetzt haben.
Normalerweise muss das
viel kürzer sein und es muss vor allem
auch etabliert werden, dass es okay ist, wenn man nichts
sagt. Okay, bla bla bla.
Moment, was?
Ausbildung und die langjährige
praktische Erfahrung in positiver
Psychologie.
Big Brain, Alter, jetzt geht's ab.
Und systemischen
Systemischen
Business Coaching oder vergleichbar wie
NLP Master.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
NLP
Practitioner Certificate.
Ey, es
gibt in diesem Bereich so unglaublich
viel Scheiße einfach nur.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Mindestens 5 Jahre umfassen
theoretisches und praktisches Wissen zu den
Frameworks Scrum, naja, was sonst?
Also, komm.
Mit Zertifizierung mindestens
ACSM und
CSP.
SM ist Scrum Master, denke ich mal.
Und Safe.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wofür es steht, aber das sagt
mir irgendwas.
Safe,
Scaled Agile Framework, genau.
So wie über
OKRs und Kanban. Okay, ich kann
eine Tabelle hin und her schieben.
Von technologischen, ach du Scheiße,
was ein Geschwätz.
Boah, da kriegst du ja Anfälle, wenn du
das liest, ey.
Benefits, Teilzeit.
Wie du das in Teilzeit machen willst, bin ich mal gespannt.
Flexible Weiterbildungsangebote,
ach du große
Neune, ey.
Meine Güte, ey, die Telekom.
Agile
Coach.
Elsa sagt, habe die Woche auch
eine Stelle mit 10 Jahren Go-Erfahrung gesehen.
Oh, 10 Jahre Go ist
nicht schlecht. Go ist ja, wenn es
mit 8 und Karre mal 10 Jahre alt.
Am besten ist
man noch der Entwickler. Ja, genau.
Man hat es erfunden.
Jolle, gebe ich dir recht. Ich denke, wie der größte
Schwachsinn überhaupt, ja.
Okay, in Frankfurt suchen die anscheinend nichts.
Da kann man nichts machen. Wenn die Telekom
nichts sucht, kann man uns heute nicht auslassen
über die Telekom. Schüler, Studenten,
Absolventen, Professionals.
Okay.
Professionals, wir sind Professionals.
Hast du schon
Agile im Korea TTS?
Nee.
Ihre Karriere als Professional.
Experten, Führungskarriere.
Okay, ich bin Experte. Zeig mal her, was
empfiehlt mir die Telekom?
Auslass, gehen wir fort.
Ich könnte mich einfach in Ruhe meine Arbeit machen lassen
und mir nicht auf den Sack gehen.
Wer will denn sowas?
Okay,
das ist so eine typische Sache. Wenn das jemand
will und da Bock drauf hat,
ist es gut, dass es das gibt.
Und dann ist es auch schön, dass er es machen kann.
Aber aus meiner Erfahrung
sind die meisten IT-Leute
jetzt nicht so
die extrovertiertesten
Auslandsreise-Fans.
Um es mal vorsichtig
auszudrücken. Also die
haben es aber schlichtweg keinen Bock drauf.
Und ich habe es auch so.
Lasst mich doch einfach meine Arbeit machen.
Geht mir nicht mit zig Bullshit
zwischendurch auf den Sack.
Lasst mich doch einfach meine Arbeit machen
und gut ist.
Karrierefahrt, okay. Inhouse-Consulting.
Schau mal da.
Es ist übrigens toll, dass man als Consultant anfängt.
Also sprich, man fängt als
Consultant an.
Also sprich, man soll konsultiert werden zu Problemen.
Und man hat vorher
keine Ahnung.
Normalerweise müsste hier eigentlich noch ein paar Schritte
davor kommen, so nach dem Motto, okay,
Know-How, ich werde Consultant da drinnen.
Aber nein, ich fange als Consultant an.
Also ich habe keinen Plan und fange schon mal als Consultant an.
Genau diesen
Eindruck habe ich von unseren Consultants
auch.
Ne, ne, geh fort.
Geh fort.
Junior-Consultant, genau. Wie gesagt,
unser spezialer Zubi ist auch Junior-Consultant
geworden und
er konnte mir in seiner Fachinformatik Ausbildung
der hat einen halben Nervenzusammenbruch gekriegt,
wo ich ihn als Netzwerkkundler angefragt habe.
Und so jemand wird Junior-Consultant.
Was ist, was hast du mir da für einen Link geschickt?
Chat?
Minimum 12 Jahre
Kubernetes-Experience.
Lull.
Wenn ihr ordentlich bezahlt
habe ich, wenn ihr wollt, auch 12 Jahre Kubernetes-Experience.
Okay,
wir suchen mal nach
trendischen Sachen.
Cloud-Specialist.
Das ist langweilig.
Wir müssen mal was anderes suchen.
Wir suchen mal nach
Was könnte man mal suchen?
Ne, wir machen mal was anderes.
Wir machen mal was anderes.
Wir gucken mal nach was ganz
Klassischem.
Wir gucken mal nach einem Administrator.
Nach was ganz Klassischem.
Administration in Frankfurt.
So was ganz, ganz Klassisches.
Und mal gucken,
ob es da irgendwas Gescheites gibt.
Hier ist der DevOps-Cloud-Ingenieur am Start.
Was ganz Klassisches, okay.
Sachbearbeiter-Administration.
Administrator.
Sollten wir lieber danach suchen.
Ein Kubernetes-Administrator.
Adesso as a Service.
Was zum Teufel ist Adesso?
Oh, ich ahne,
ich ahne Buzzwords.
Und eine Sache,
die mir bei diesen ganzen
Stellenanzeigen immer nicht einleuchtend ist,
warum übertreiben,
warum müssen die am Anfang
immer so eine riesen
Abgesang
oder so eine riesen Lobes-Hymne
auf sich selbst anstimmen?
Das interessiert doch denjenigen,
der das jetzt hier gerade zum ersten Mal liest,
nicht die Bohne.
Die sollten zum Beispiel ganz,
die sollten vielleicht
ganz oben hinschreiben,
Gehaltsspanne oder so was.
Das wäre ja interessant.
Kubernetes-Administrator mit Begeisterung
für Infrastruktur und Applikationsumgebung.
Okay, bla bla.
Sie haben erst praktisch als System-Engineer
oder Application-Administrator in Projekten
mit Kubernetes oder einer Container-Plattform gesammelt.
Begeistert sich für aktuelle
Cloud-Plattform-Technologien,
sind bereit, den DevOps- und
Site-Reliability-Engineering-Ansatz
tatkräftig zu unterstützen.
Okay, ja.
Dann sind sie bei uns genau richtig.
Diese Formulierungen,
die haben sie doch auch aus irgendeinem Buch, oder?
Weil, wenn man mal ehrlich ist,
niemand
geht auf eine Bewerbungsseite
und sagt, oh, ich würde mir
so gern wünschen,
dass ich ein Begeisterter
bin
für aktuelle
Cloud-Plattformen und Technologien
und ich würde auch so gern
DevOps und Site-Reliability-Engineering
tatkräftig unterstützen.
Sagt halt keiner.
Dann sind sie bei uns genau richtig.
Sie werden Teil eines dynamischen Teams
und helfen mit, Systemlandschaft unserer Kunden
zu konzipieren,
aufzubauen.
Das ist ja alles okay.
Das klingt aber wirklich sehr vorlagenmäßig,
wie sie das geschrieben haben.
Wir hatten letztens ein paar richtig coole Stellenanzeigen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo das war.
Die waren wirklich
mit Brain geschrieben.
Sprich, wo du auch was hattest davon,
wenn du die gelesen hast.
Unterstützung bei der Vorbereitung von Java-Software-Artefakten
geht schon gut los hier.
Es ist Java.
Es fängt schon mal gut an.
Deklaration verteilen
in Helm-Charts.
Das ist ja voll angesagt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das
Charts hat.
Helm-Charts.
Ach, das ist eine extra Geschichte mit Charts
dafür, oder was?
Wie gesagt, ich wusste nicht, dass
das Charts hat.
Okay, excellent. Charts.
Deklaration von
Infrastrukturkomponenten. Terraform.
Terraform ist voll angesagt aktuell.
Für AWS, Azure und
VMware vSphere. Boah, die wollen es aber wissen.
Azure und AWS.
Und noch ein bisschen VMware.
Testen und ausrollen. Neue Software.
Stände in enger Zusammenarbeit mit Teams
aus Entwicklungsqualität. Es ist alles vollkommen
okay, was die hier wollen.
Wobei man halt sagen muss,
so rein klassische Administration ist es jetzt ja nicht.
Unterstützung bei der
Entwicklung von
betriebsunterstützenden Containern.
Das ist alles
in Ordnung.
Ihre Skills.
Erfolgreich abgeschlossen bleiben.
Immer das gleiche.
Gute Linux und BSD.
Jetzt
gehen sie aber in die Vollen.
Mit BSD-Kenntnissen wirst du
nicht so viele Leute finden.
Das kann ich euch sagen.
Aber Kenntnisse
sind ja bei manchen Leuten auch schon.
Wir hatten mal einen, der hat gesagt,
er ist fortgeschritten in, also fortgeschrittene
Kenntnisse in VMware.
Und als wir den gefragt haben, was er denn gemacht hat,
hat er gemeint, eine Ubuntu-VM installiert.
Das ist kein Witz. Klingt so, als hätte ich es mir ausgedacht.
Ich weiß, aber das war das, warum er
fortgeschrittene Kenntnisse in VMware hatte.
Grundlegendes Verständnis von
Netzwerkprotokollen und Architekturen.
TCP, IP, MPLS.
Peering, Hub und
Okay, da wäre es bei mir schon mal raus.
Was ist
Hub and Spoke?
Nahbespeiche?
Was?
Okay.
Hub und Spoke, alles klar.
Ich meine, es ist angebliches Netzwerkprotokoll
bzw. Netzwerkarchitektur.
Ich habe ernsthaft keine Ahnung,
was damit gemeint ist.
Vielleicht wollen die mir
damit sagen, wie man am besten
Netzwerkgeräte miteinander
verbindet bzw. wie man das am besten
auf einer Architektur her aufbaut,
dass es
ordentlich läuft.
Pro Gaming Sebi
schreibt,
Moment, ich kann das nicht einfach zeigen.
Kubernetes oder Docker?
Möchte mir über den Sommer 1 vielleicht beides anschauen.
Die Frage stellt sich gar nicht.
Docker.
Du wirst
hoffnungslos gegen die Wand fahren,
wenn du irgendwie was Kubernetes-mäßig machen
möchtest, wenn du nicht ein bisschen
Linux-Container-Grundlagen hast und da ist
Docker nun mal das Ding, was sich durchgesetzt hat.
Also
das da musst du machen, das da
und dann später kannst du dir vielleicht
noch ein bisschen das da angucken.
Aber das da, also Docker ist für den Heimbereich
auch um größten Ordnung sinnvoller als Docker.
Es ist ja gar nicht
entweder oder.
Docker ist für Lokale
ein bisschen Container laufen lassen,
vielleicht mit Docker Compose
ein bisschen das managen
und Kubernetes ist eher so
Orchestrierungsgeschichte von Containern.
Die Frage ist gar nicht entweder oder,
sondern, also in deinem Fall, wenn du sagst
was du lernen sollst, Docker, ganz klar.
Das da zuerst und danach das.
Hast du das schon gesehen?
Ne, was ist das?
Äh, Moment.
Die lassen ihr JavaScript
von WebArchive.org
ausliefern?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist ja Big Brain, dann spart man sich Traffic.
Das ist ja,
dass da nicht schon mehr drauf gekommen sind.
Das ist Big Brain, was ist das für Traffic?
Das ist Traffic spart, Alter.
Das Support checkt es nicht.
Ah, okay, okay.
Okay, jetzt hast du auch gecheckt, alles klar.
Das ist ja toll.
Lustig.
Nice.
Ähm.
Okay, das liest sich alles relativ
normal, was die hier haben wollen.
Auch keine komischen
Sachen zwischendrin, dass du noch Projektmanagement
und First Level Support mitmachen sollst,
wie bei anderen Sachen.
In
drei Wochen hab ich meinen
Azure DevOps
Fünf-Tage-Kurs.
Danach bin ich
abgegradet der Hackermann.
Guck mal, 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung
reicht nicht mehr. Die brauchen 12-Faktor-
Authentifizierung.
Ja, der AZ-900 ist übelst
Resident-Sleeper gewesen.
Und
ich gehe davon aus, dass der DevOps-Kurs auch
mega Resident-Sleeper wäre.
Wird.
Ich weiß, dass damit nicht
12-Faktor-Authentifizierung gemeint ist.
Aber es liest sich wie 12-Faktor-Authentifizierung,
oder?
Ja, jetzt hier, Big Brain, was wollen sie hier haben?
Der Karton
Plast, was? Die Karton
Plast Group, ah ja.
Also, das erwartet sie.
First- und Second-Level-Anwendungs-Support.
Okay, Instant Rage-Quit.
Windows 10, Office 365,
Drucker!
Instant Rage-Quit.
Endkunden-Support. Nein, nein, nein.
Leute.
Wie viele Stunden arbeitest du
die Woche? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich kann es dir nicht sagen. Also,
irgendwie 7,5 Stunden
oder so am Tag.
7,5 Stunden mal 4.
Aber 7 mal 4?
30?
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
32 Stunden oder so?
30 Stunden?
Irgendwie so. 30 Stunden
arbeite ich.
Okay, die suchen wirklich,
das finde ich cool, dass es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Die suchen wirklich so den ganz
klassischen
Drucker-Anschließer.
Also Drucker scheinen sehr wichtig
zu sein, weil Drucker haben die sogar 2 mal drinstehen.
Ach, und nebenbei machst du noch
Monitoring der gesamten IT-Infrastruktur.
Alles klar.
Okay, geht doch.
Wie hast du die 30 Stunden verhandelt?
Konditionen
gleich geblieben.
Naja, ich kriege weniger Geld,
weil ich anstatt 38 Stunden
oder so nur noch 30 Stunden
arbeite. Klar, dass
ich die gleiche Kohle kriege wie vorher. Ist ja klar.
Wenn,
wäre natürlich noch viel besser, aber
es ist nicht so.
Aber ansonsten hat sich nichts geändert.
Genau das gleiche, plus einfach weniger Stunden.
Die Z-Bank.
Was wollen die?
Was ist FCSI?
Fixi.
Ach, das heißt so bei denen.
Okay.
First- und Second-Level-Support im Rahmen
Fiski.
Administration mit Admin-GUI und Saga.
Die erwarten doch nicht ernsthaft, dass irgendjemand...
Was ist das?
Server.
Age of Conan. Alles klar.
Die erwarten doch nicht, dass das jemand kennt.
Planung und Umsetzung
der System-Release-Wechsel.
Technische Beratung
bei IT, Strukturfragen, Analyse-Optimierung.
Es liest sich alles...
Heute ist wenig Trash dabei.
Also das liest sich alles relativ realistisch.
Aber wir müssen
eher bei den krassen Startups gucken.
Oh je.
Oh je, das ist ein Bullshit-Shop.
Das sieht man sofort schon.
Gar nicht mal von der Beschreibung her.
Aber Admin-Mann im Krankenhaus.
Ich glaube, da hast du keinen Spaß.
Du bist umgeben von
technisch unfähigen Leuten wahrscheinlich.
Und es ist auch noch wichtig,
was du machst, sonst kratzen Leute ab.
Das würde ich mir nicht geben.
In Offenbach.
Ob da Haftbefehl schon mal drin gewesen ist?
Okay, was macht man hier?
Sicherstellen des User-Supports.
Okay, die wollen einen, der alles macht.
Ich seh schon.
Administration der Rechner- und Serversysteme.
Sicherstellung des User-Supports
bezüglich Hardware, Betriebssystem, Office,
Umfeld, Mailclient.
Boah, fuck, du musst ja echt alles machen.
Planung, Durchführung, Verwaltung,
regelmäßiger Backup.
Beschaffung, Konfiguration,
Installation neuer...
Okay, du machst alles.
Du machst alles IT.
Du machst komplett alles IT, so wie es aussieht.
Betreuung und Installation von Software
und systemnaher Soft...
Was?
Betreuung und Installation von Software
und systemnaher Software.
Überwachung und Portikulierung der Funktionsfähigkeit
der Server und der aktiven Netz...
Ach, Netzwerkinfrastruktur machst du auch noch mit.
Beseitigung aufgetretener Störungen
gemeinsam mit Soft- und Hardware-Lieferanten.
Auch noch.
Betreuung und Wartung der passiven Netz...
Netzwerk-Monitoring machst du auch noch.
Verstehe.
Betreuung, Wartung, Austausch und Neueinsatz...
Ach, Endkundensupport und Aufbau der Arbeitsplätze
machst du auch noch.
Unterstützung der Anwender bei Software-Nutzung,
also Support und Office erklären auch noch.
Pflege...
Die Homepage machst du auch noch?
Benutzer- und E-Mail-Kontenverwaltung...
Okay, Mail-Administration machst du auch noch.
Eigenverantwortliche Erstellung
von firmenspezifischen Auswertungen.
What the fuck?
Was geht, wenn's fertig ist?
Also, ja, das kann
alles ein Administrator machen.
Aber das ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel
für einen Administrator.
Was hat der? 400 Wochenstunden, oder was?
Okay, also was
wollen sie haben?
Gute Kenntnisse im Bereich der Windows-Betriebssysteme.
Da bin ich schon mal raus.
Also nicht, dass ich das jemals
freiwillig machen würde.
Dazu müsste ich
irgendeine Straftat begehen
und zu gemeinnütziger Arbeit
verurteilt werden.
Und das Gericht müsste irgendwie anordnen,
dass ich das machen muss,
damit ich das machen würde.
Unter Androhung von Knast.
Sonst würde ich das nicht machen.
Das würde ich im Leben nicht machen, ja.
Kenntnisse im Netzwerkbereich.
TCP, IP, WAN, LAN, VPN.
WAN, LAN, VPN.
Bereitschaft zu
teamorientierter Arbeitsstil.
Wieso teamorientierter Arbeitsstil?
Welches Team?
Du brauchst ja noch kein Team mehr.
Du machst doch alles.
Erfahrung mit Datenbanken.
Auch noch.
Das muss ich mir im Punkt machen.
Das ist was, was ich flamen kann.
Sehr gute Deutschkenntnisse.
Diskretion und Loyalität.
Ich...
Das ist
zu einem gewissen Grad
kaufbar, würde ich mal behaupten.
Also sprich,
wenn das Gehalt gut ist,
ist Loyalität sicherlich auch gut.
Wenn das Gehalt ein Apfel und ein Ei ist,
dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es manche mit Diskretion
und Loyalität nicht so ernst nehmen.
Einsatzbereitschaft,
Motivation,
Flexibilität im Aufgabenbereich.
Das heißt, du darfst doch ab und zu mal die OP,
äh,
den OP-Tisch putzen, oder wie?
Grundeinstellung zur
Nächstenliebe und
Mittragen?
Mittragen!
Mittragen, Alter!
Hahaha!
Mittragen!
Mittra...
Hahaha!
Guck mal, Michael, 50 Milliarden, boi!
Mit... Ich find Mittragen viel besser.
Unseres Leitbildes.
Was ist denn euer Leitbild?
Leitbild. Steht nirgendwo,
was euer Leitbild ist.
Was ist denn euer Leitbild?
Grundeinstellung zur Nächstenliebe.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Diese drei Worte,
ich
find die wirklich gut.
Also, sowas
könnten die gerne mehr
auch noch bei anderen Stellenanzeigen irgendwie
reinpacken. Ich find eine
Grundeinstellung zur Nächstenliebe, find ich nicht
verkehrt. Ich mein, gut, klar,
hier geht's ums Krankenhaus oder so, aber das ist
ein Job, den ich im Leben nicht machen würde, aber diese
drei Worte in Kombi find ich eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Diese Einstellungen sollten mehr
Leute haben.
Der Q-Chat, genau.
So, wir bieten.
Leistungsgerechte Vergütung nach dem gültigen
Tarifvertrag AVR.
Ja.
Welche Stufe? Welche was?
Tarifvertrag
AVR, gucken wir mal.
Ah.
What the fuck?
Was? Äh.
Ja, welches davon ist es?
Mitarbeiter im Pflegedienst.
Aber das ist doch kein Pflegedienst.
Äh.
Drei? What the fuck?
Was ist das für ein Rechner? Das ist doch kein Gehaltsrechner.
Das ist eine fertige Tabelle.
Zum Rechner.
Hessen? Wo ist Hessen?
Alter, wer hat diese Seite wieder gemacht?
Ich mach jetzt einfach mal das da auf, ist egal.
Geburtsjahr, okay.
1984.
Was weiß ich? Okay, das kann ich nicht
ausrechnen. Also,
ich muss ehrlich sagen, wir bieten fällt
wirklich
sehr
ähm
aus, ja.
Ich mein, sie bieten Geld.
Das ist ja schon mal die Grundvoraussetzung dafür,
dass man da überhaupt jemand dran denkt, da zu arbeiten.
Dass sie, ja.
Regelmäßig freundlich und kollegial ist.
Da hab ich so meine Zweifel.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass da
ziemlich oft Stress und
dicke Luft ist. Das ist Krankenhaus.
Da willst du nicht arbeiten.
Ihre Aussage, kräftige Bewerber...
Das ist so ein Ding,
wo es mir irgendwie
in den Fingern juckt,
einfach mal zu fragen, was es für Geld
gibt.
Das interessiert mich brennend,
was es da für Geld gibt.
Das Problem ist, ich kann ja nicht einfach fragen.
Wobei, warum eigentlich nicht?
Wie gesagt,
ich will es auf keinen Fall machen. Mich interessiert
aber echt einfach mal,
was es dafür gibt. Ich könnte
wetten, es gibt nichts.
Es gibt irgendwie
30k im Jahr
oder so. Es wird wahrscheinlich nix.
Das bookmark ich mir mal.
Ich glaube, ich schreib da echt mal
eine E-Mail hin.
Was es da so für
Gehaltsaussichten
gibt. Wahrscheinlich 25k
oder sowas. Na, ich kann mich da nicht
bewerben. Da müsst ihr eine Bewerbung schreiben.
Ich glaub, es geht los. Außerdem will ich mich da gar nicht bewerben.
Ich will einfach mal...
Hast du schon mal die Website?
Okay, die gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ketteler Krankenhaus.
Offenbach.
Oh, Schlaflabor.
Oh.
klopft an.
1995 guckt vorbei und will
seine Website wieder haben.
Eine Babygalerie haben sie.
Immerhin.
Ein paar niedliche Babys.
Aber das ist wirklich 1995
hat angeklopft und will die Website wieder haben.
International Patient.
Okay, muss erst mal ranzoomen.
Okay.
Jetzt wisst ihr auch,
warum die jemand suchen,
wie sich um den Web auftritt.
Das Internet auftritt.
Warum die jemand suchen, der sich um die Website kümmert.
Was ist das da?
Oh, das Leitbild.
Das ist ja das, was wir wissen wollten.
Oh, da gibt's ein Video zu.
Liebe lindert Leiden.
Hallo?
Man darf nicht mal spulen.
What the fuck?
Spulen nicht erlaubt.
Denied.
Okay, das muss man jetzt nicht geben.
Was ist denn die Babygalerie?
Naja, wahrscheinlich neugeborene Babys,
die da im Krankenhaus auf die Welt gekommen sind oder so.
Spulen und gleich
Nächstenliebe.
Das stimmt. Ich finde ein bisschen mehr
Nächstenliebe beim Videoplayer hätte nicht
verkehrt geschadet.
Okay.
Ich will die jetzt nicht zu sehr
flamen, weil
die haben kein Budget.
Die kriegen auch kein Budget.
Die sind wahrscheinlich
komplett am Limit.
Die haben, die kommen nicht hinterher
und die brauchen irgendeinen, der sich
um die IT kümmert.
Und haben kein Geld, um ihn zu bezahlen.
Wofür sie auch nicht so wirklich was können.
Also
Mich
interessiert echt brennend, was man da kriegt.
Ich glaube,
ich frag die einfach mal.
Ich glaube, ich schreib da einfach mal ne Mail hin,
was mich interessieren würde,
was man da so bekommt.
Ob das dann eben Tarif hat.
Welche Stufe man bekommen
könnte.
Ähm.
Das würde mich echt interessieren.
Weil ich wette, ich könnte wetten, das ist
saumäßig wenig. 30k, 25k
oder sowas.
Was letzte Preis
schreib ich dann in die Mail rein. Genau.
Was letzte Gehalt.
Ja.
25k nicht bisschen arg wenig. Doch.
Natürlich ist das arg wenig.
Aber ich glaube, es wird arg wenig sein.
Und die Augenklinik.
Ah ja gut, das passt ja schon mal dazu.
Guck mal, Hyper-V machen die.
Fundierte Kenntnisse im Bereich
IP-Routing und Subnetting.
Das ist wieder irgendwas, was die
Personalfrau geschrieben hat
und man ihr gesagt hat, schreib das rein.
Ja, PlopsRusher.
Ich hab irgendwas gesagt, was halt wenig ist.
Es ist wahrscheinlich unglaublich
wenig, was du kriegst.
Deswegen interessiert es mich ja auch.
SAP, SAP
SAP? Der Wetterau-Kreis.
Moment.
Da war jemand mit einem Feuerlöscher.
Ne, das ist was ganz was anderes.
Moment, das stimmt überhaupt nicht hier.
Public Administration.
So viel SAP überall.
Soll ich eine Mail schreiben?
Wenn du willst, ja.
Das musst du... Kannst du dir überlegen,
ob du das machst.
Ich stifte
keinen dazu an, dir irgendwie zuzuspammen jetzt.
Nicht,
dass du es dir mit dem Kettler-Krankenhaus verscherzt.
Ich schreibe dir da nicht
alle ihr Spasten, was letzte Gehalt.
Ich schreibe da eine ganz normale Mail hin.
Wie soll ich mir da mit denen verscherzen?
So, Plusline.
Von denen habe ich schon mal was gehört.
Ich glaube, die machen bei uns irgendwas.
Excellent Soundtrack.
Von denen habe ich schon mal was gehört.
Ich glaube, die machen bei uns für uns irgendwas.
Managed Services.
Ich glaube, die managen irgendwas für uns.
Ähm.
Bla bla bla.
Mit einem echten Interesse
für Linux und Open Source.
Okay, das wäre ja schon was für mich.
Wenn sie mit der Kommandozeile
und dem Editor bereits sicher umgehen können.
Excellent.
Sie suchen jemand
für Apache MySQL Postfix.
Wir machen sie vertraut
mit O wird KVM.
Da fehlt ein Komma.
Vmware OpenStack.
Sie nutzen aktuellste wie Puppet, Ansible,
Icinga. Nein, ich mag
Oldschool Nagios. Nagios Beste.
Grafana, Elastic Search,
Logs, Dash, Kibana.
Das, das, das, die coolen Leute
sagen, das ist Elk.
Elastic Search, Logs, Dash, Kibana.
Klingt zu doof.
Deswegen ist es der Elk-Stack.
Weil, besser.
Space Walk, das verwendet noch jemand.
Der hat mal einen ehemaligen Dokumentator,
der hat immer gesagt, der Space Walk.
Der konnte Space Walk nicht aussprechen.
Hat immer auf Hessisch gesagt,
der Space Walk.
Das ist aber,
schon ewig her, da hatten wir selbst noch
Spacewalk.
Spacewalk ist für Red Hat so ein Management
Frontend.
Web Frontend, wo du ein bisschen
Red Hat Systeme rudimentär
mitmanagen kannst.
Und nicht mal rudimentär,
da kannst du relativ viel mitmachen.
Spacemark.
Forman.
Catello habe ich noch nie gesehen, dass das jemand einsetzt.
Forman ist für
Puppet so ein Web Frontend.
Tja gut,
das klingt doch eigentlich ganz okay.
Wir bieten an.
Steile Lernkurve.
Ob das jetzt so eine gute,
ob das so toll ist, was man anbietet.
Ich finde das ist gar nicht schlecht
geschrieben, ganz ehrlich.
Warum nicht?
Musik ist aus.
Warum ist die Musik aus?
Ohm Support.
Ellen Wille Hair Company.
Klingt ja schon wieder absolut
Big Brain.
Oh, das ist Mode, Mode
Zeug.
Der Frasier.
Ey, das wäre glaube ich der optimale
Job. Mal angenommen, man hätte Friseur gelernt
und dann Fachinformatiker.
Dann wären wir hier richtig gut
aufgehoben.
Radbacher.
Ja, wahrscheinlich eher Radbacher.
Das ist, die Experten finden, das ist irgendein
Personalverschacherungsding, oder?
Ja, das ist irgendein Personalverschacher
Typ.
Was ist das denn?
Sopra.
Patinprogramm.
Okay, du hast permanent einen bei dir sitzen, der dir auf den Sack geht.
Beratung als Reisen.
Igitt.
Geh fort.
Aber heute ist gar nicht so viel
Mist dabei gewesen.
Was stand da?
Windows 2008? Ernsthaft?
Moment, wo waren wir?
Hier.
Red Hat 6.
Fuck, Alter.
Red Hat 6?
Ist ja antik.
7 wird noch supported, ja.
2008, keine Ahnung,
ob das noch supported ist, aber das ist auch schon ganz schön
alt.
Und jünger.
Okay, man hätte auch
neuer schreiben können.
Was haben die sonst noch? Apache, Apache
Reverse Proxy, JBoss, IES,
SVN.
Okay, die sind oldschool unterwegs.
Die sind oldschool
unterwegs.
Erfahrung mit der Programmiersprache.
Sql, Bash, CMD, Igitt, MySQL, MSSql, ja, also die bekannte Programmiersprache, MSSql, MySQL und Oracle.
SVN ist das Beste.
Also Reise, Reisegeschichten, das würde ich allein schon aus dem Grund nicht machen.
Erfahr...
Was? Unsere Aufgaben, deine Perspektive, Erfahrung im technischen Betrieb von teils hochverfügbaren Fachleuten.
Ja, was?
Sind das jetzt unsere Aufgaben oder meine Perspektiven?
Also...
Was soll dieser Satz sagen? Dass die Erfahrung
haben im technischen Betrieb von...
Wer hat das nicht
im
Administrationsbereich?
Die meisten Sachen sollen 24-7
verfügbar sein.
Die Betonung liegt auf sollen.
Du sollst das haben?
Okay. Aber dafür gibt's ja
unsere Erwartungen, deine Fähigkeiten.
Okay, was auch immer.
Oh, so viel Kekwe.
Wie gesagt, war heute etwas...
Planloser, spontan Stream.
Eineinhalb Stunden.
Ich bin einfach mal angekommen. Es gab ja nix.
Ich hatte nix großartig vor.
Aber es war trotzdem schön, dass so viele Leute dabei waren.
Exzellent.
Ich denke mal, wir sehen uns morgen, Nachmittag oder so wieder.
Ich hab nämlich wirklich mal Bock drauf, wieder ein paar Stunden Battlefield 3 zu spielen.
Vielleicht auch im Stream machen.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht machen wir auch noch ein bisschen Technik-Kram morgen.
Muss man mal gucken.
Und ich würde sagen, Chat, wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
See you.